dalila et couturières et auto
entrepreneuse depuis un an et demi elle
est installée en france il y a neuf ans
tu si dans son pays d'origine au
portugal elle était chef d'une
entreprise de linge de maison ici
dalila a dû tout reconstruire j'ai
commencé à être très attiré par la
petite piste rio sic je faisais déjà
avant mais en france j'ai trouvé le
problème de tous les styles qui sont
différents de mon petit pays et donc
j'ai faim j'ai suivi une formation avec
un tapissier que ce soit la partie
rurale compte pour les fauteuils dali
les a mis en pratique son savoir faire
au château de breteuil
elle s'est occupée des tapisseries des
rideaux ou encore d'une robe créée
spécialement pour une exposition la rob
adams a été un défi que j'ai accepté au
château ça m'a fait très plaisir de la
faire j'aime beaucoup tout ce qui est ce
genre de robe d'europe comme ça admet
mme larocque marié tout ça j'aime
beaucoup tout ça dalila aime relever des
challenges les défis stimule sa
créativité
exemple avec cette petite botte de
couture que personne n'a encore réussi à
restaurer ou après donc le ciseau va
rentrer ici toutes les petites pièces
vont trouver sa place aujourd'hui dalila
travail pour des antiquaires parisiens
et des particuliers et cherche à étendre
son réseau
je fais tout ce qui à linge de maison
pour commencer donc des les rideaux les
embrasse les voilà je les coupe vanier
les nappes chemin de table tous les
serviettes tout ce qui à linge de maison
et après donc j'ai fait aussi la
tapisserie soit la tapisserie murale que
j'aime beaucoup faire aussi et sinon les
fauteuils les chaises la can à pied
l'état morel
ce genre de l'accessoire dépend comme
moderne peu importe pour la restauration
complète de ce fauteuil il a fallu deux
jours de travail à dalila pour refaire
les sangles replacer les ressorts
remettre le crin et enfin qu'outre un
nouveau tissu et poser des clous les
prix varient en fonction de l'état du
fauteuil allant de 250 à 800 euros
lorsqu'un projet arrive à sa fin en
dalila récupère les chutes de tissus
elle confectionne avec de petits
poussins qu'elles offrent ensuite à ses
clients pour parfaire la décoration